Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva afirmó que
Brasil está de vuelta en el escenario
internacional el presidente electo
criticó el orden mundial actual diciendo
que no debe ser que los líderes y
vencedores de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
sea a quienes decidan en el Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU en cambio Lula
propone una nueva gobernanza global
gobernanza que es todavía más necesaria
en la crisis climática por eso Lula dijo
que volvió para cobrar Lo prometido en
alusión a los 100.000 millones de
dólares que prometieron los países
desarrollados desde 2009 y que todavía
no han pagado a los países más
vulnerables Lula recordó que no hay un
mundo sano sin una amazonía sana y por
eso se comprometió a que en su gobierno
se frenará la deforestación y también
anunció la creación de una cumbre de los
países amazónicos una vez se la suma el
cargo el próximo año Lula también se
comprometió a combatir los crímenes a y
habló de revitalizar las instituciones
que durante la presidencia de Jair
bolsonaro fueron desmanteladas como el
sistema de monitoreo y fiscalización de
deforestación y el fondo amazonía que
según anunció Lula Noruega y Alemania ya
están dispuestos a descongelar los 500
millones que congelaron durante el
gobierno de bolso
recordó que defenderá de manera
vehemente que un estado amazónico
brasileño sea la sede de la Cup que se
realizará en 2025 y también reiteró la
creación de un Ministerio de pueblos
originarios para los indígenas Luna
terminó su discurso haciendo un llamado
a la esperanza con la acción inmediata